Et bien bienvenue à tous dans cette nouvelle vidéo, dans laquelle nous allons parler d’un sujet qui me fait du bien.
Bon en ce moment ça se lâche un peu sur les sujets, après les animaux qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Qu’est-ce que c’est ? Les mods sur les jeux vidéo !
Aucun rapport, c’est bon.
Oui, je vais vous parler de ça parce qu’il y a des mods qui sont extrêmement drôles
Mais avant je vais vous parler un petit peu de l’histoire des mods sur les jeux vidéo.
Personnellement, c’est un truc que j’adore pour plusieurs raisons.
Et j’aimerais vous expliquer déjà ce que c’est et vous dire pourquoi je trouve que c’est quelque chose de génial.
Sur certains jeux vidéo, il est possible que les joueurs créent un mod, c’est à dire un nouveau contenu, une nouvelle manière de  jouer au jeu auquel on joue
et c’est quelque chose qui est apparu dans les années 80
En tout cas, les premiers mods de jeux qui sont devenus assez populaires pour l’époque, c’était dans les années 80.
Il y avait par exemple, à l’époque, un jeu qui s’appelait "Castle Wolfenstein" dans lequel on combattait des nazis
et il y a des joueurs qui ont créé un mod où ça remplace tous les nazis par les Schtroumpfs.
Et ils ont appelé le mode "Castle Smurfenstein", donc Castle schtroumpfenstein en français.
Personnellement, j’ai commencé à jouer à des mods sur Counter Strike 1.6, il y a pas mal de temps.
Je jouais beaucoup au mod surf, pour ceux qui connaissent.
C’est un mod où il y avait des rampes et on pouvait finalement faire du surf dessus et voler, c’était vraiment sympa.
Il y avait aussi le mod zombie qui était incroyable, je me suis mis un doigt dans l’œil à l’instant, un replay et le fameux mod Death Run qui m’a tant fait kiffer et rager.
Bref, je pense que les mods de Counter Strike illustrent parfaitement pourquoi c’est cool qu’il y ait des mods
et pourquoi c’est cool que des joueurs passent du temps à créer ça gratuitement et bénévolement, la plupart du temps.
Des fois, attention, ça peut leur apporter de l’argent.
D’ailleurs, Counter-Strike est à la base un mod de Half Life créé par un mec, Minh Le.
Je ne sais pas comment ça se prononce.
C’est lui qui a introduit le thème des terroristes vs les antiterroristes
avec des objectifs qui varient selon la map
dont l’objectif le plus connu est bien évidemment le « amorcer ou désamorcer la bombe ».
Je trouve ça ouf, moi j’ai appris que récemment qu’en fait à la base Counter-Strike était un mod de Half Life
et que ce n’est pas Valve qui a eu l’idée de Counter-Strike.
Ces deux mecs en fait, ce gars avec son pote qui gérait le site qui se sont dit
« Putain, mais ça tuerait si on ajoutait ce thème-là avec tel et tel objectif à accomplir,
tel et tel mod de jeu... »
Je trouve ça incroyable.
Et du coup, parfois, quand le mod est vraiment bon, bah ça peut rapporter de l’argent à ses créateurs.
Comme c’est le cas pour ces 2 personnes qui ont été embauchées par Valve.
Et ils ont bien fait putain quand on voit ce qu’est devenu Counter-Strike, mon gars,
c’est l’un des jeux vidéo les plus joués au monde,
c’est l’un des jeux qui a traversé le temps le mieux, qui a le mieux vieilli,
c’est toujours un classique du fps et putain ça vient de deux mecs qui ont créé un mod à la base.
Je trouve ça incroyable.
Alors c’est marrant parce qu’on se dirait qu’il y a tout un truc de propriété intellectuelle.
On se dirait « Mais attend, les mecs ont créé ce mod là à l’époque, c’était un truc qui appartenait à Valve quand même.
Donc ils ont créé quelque chose à partir de ce que Valve a créé.
Donc ce qu’ils ont créé à qui ça appartient exactement ? »
Mais, en fait, beaucoup d’éditeurs et de studios de développement sont pour les mods.
Il y en a même qui fournissent des kits pour simplifier la vie aux mecs qui créent des mods.
Parce que ça fait tout simplement vivre leur jeu,
ça propose du nouveau contenu gratuit aux joueurs, qui ont déjà acheté le jeu.
Et même parfois dans les cas où le mod est vraiment incroyable
ben les gens vont acheter le jeu juste pour jouer au mod qu’un mec a créé.
C’est vraiment un truc donnant donnant
et c’est aussi plus simple pour euh les mecs qui ont envie de créer une sorte de mini jeux,
bah de faire un mod dans un jeu qui existe déjà, plutôt que de devoir coder un jeu entièrement de A à Z.
Ça crée des vrais success-stories comme pour Counter-Strike et aussi par exemple comme pour les Battle Royale !
Les Battle Royale ça vient d’un mec qui s’appelle Brendan Green,
qui a créé un mod de ArmA 2, le mod inspiré du film Battle Royale, le film japonais.
Et il a ensuite été repéré par les développeurs de H1Z1 pour faire la même chose avec H1Z1,
créé le mod H1Z1 Battle Royale.
Et ensuite, ce gars-là a quitté Daybreak, les développeurs de H1Z1,
pour s’associer avec un mec en Corée du Sud qui avait un studio de jeu, et créer avec lui PUBG.
Et tout ça part juste d’un mod que ce gars a créé pour ArmA 2.
C’est incroyable comme histoire, c’est fou.
Et ensuite, Epic Games, donc qui ont Fortnite,
ont employé ce gars, pour créer Fortnite Battle Royale.
Pas du tout !
Ils ont juste pris l’idée, c’est entièrement faux.
C’est là où il y a des fois des petits conflits, des petits vols d'idées...
En fait, le problème de Brendan Greene c’est qu’il a créé un truc qui est incroyable,
mais qui est générique.
C’est comme on ne va pas verser des royalties au mec qui a créé les fps,
au mec qui a créé les rpg...
Et Brendan Greene, il a créé vraiment un mod de jeu à part entière, le Battle Royale.
Et encore, lui s’en est bien sorti, puisqu’il a pu créer son propre jeu
et qui s’est vendu à des millions d’exemplaires donc il s’est mis bien.
Mais, des fois, voilà, il y a des mecs qui font un mod qui est vraiment innovant et cool,
et malgré qu’ils aient bossés énormément sur le truc, bah s’est repris ailleurs, etc.,
et ils n’obtiennent jamais vraiment de compensation monétaire.
Donc il n’y a pas mal de teams de mod, parce que c’est des teams,
des fois les gens bossent à plusieurs dizaines de personnes pour certains sur un même mod,
parce que c’est beaucoup de temps, mine de rien, faire un mod,
bon ça dépend ce que tu fais, vous allez voir, mais il y a des mods qui sont vraiment complexes à faire.
Le souci c’est qu’un mod fait par des joueurs ne peut pas être vendu,
il y a par exemple le mod Skyrim Together,
qui permet à des joueurs de se rejoindre en ligne sur Skyrim,
qui est un jeu à la base solo, mais il est interdit de vendre le mod
parce que le mod dépend d’un contenu qui n’appartient pas à ceux qui l’ont créé
qui en l’occurrence qui appartient à Bethesda.
Et donc du coup, ce qu’ils font, c’est qu’ils créent une campagne de financement
donc un Patreon ou ce genre de truc.
Et actuellement, au moment où je fais la vidéo,
ces gars-là ils sont quand même backés à hauteur de 23 mille dollars par mois pour leurs mods Skyrim Together,
donc ils se mettent très très bien et c’est mérité.
Petit bémol ! Ils sont accusés (euh…) les gars qui ont fait Skyrim Together,
par une autre team d'avoir volés du code.
Et ouais d'avoir volé des lignes de codes à l'autre team qui du coup est...
a un vrai manque à gagner. Et c'est là où on rentre un peu dans le deep modding
où il y a des grosses embrouilles comme ça, il y a des gens qui volent du code à d'autres gens
pour faire des mods qui rapportent de l'argent d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Et parfois même y a des gens qui font des mods géniaux, que moi à l'époque sur GTA 5
j'avais, j'avais fait une vidéo où j'utilisais des mods
dont un mod où il y avait plein d'avions qui se crashaient de partout,
et en fait ce mod là c'était un putain de virus, voilà !
Je l'ai appris deux semaines après, j'ai été ravi de me dire que des millions de gens avaient vu cette vidéo
et avait probablement téléchargé ce mod qui contenait un logiciel malveillant
visant à voler tes identifiants de plein de sites. Cool !!
Voilà vous savez tout, c'était une belle intro,
bon y a plein d'infos que je n'ai pas données, etc.
je vulgarise pas mal le truc comme d'habitude
je vulgarise un truc déjà vulgarisé dans ce que j'ai vu.
C'est pour le level de Squeezie,
il est où ? Il est où ?
Il y a donc des mods assez sérieux assez cool,
il y a aussi des mods qui sont juste nawak,
c'est vraiment des gens qui les ont faits pour faire marrer la communauté
et pas du tout pour gagner de l'argent ou quoi que ce soit.
Et aujourd'hui c'est ces mods là qu'on va checker ensemble
en commençant par mon préféré, DPO 23
qui est un gars qui a une chaîne YouTube où juste il fait un mod
qui en fait augmente les expressions faciales de 500%.
Du coup les cinématiques n'ont plus aucune espèce de sens.
Ça me fait déjà rire.
Je ne sais pas si vous allez être sensible à ça, mais moi comme je joue beaucoup au jeu ça me fait rire.
Et non le gaming ce n'est pas fini du tout c'est faux je n'ai jamais autant joué aux jeux de ma vie.
Il fait des petits zooms.
AAAAHHHH ! Mais il me fait flipper.
Il fait plus peur que les zombies de Resident Evil comme ça mon gars le héros c'est horrible.
Ça dégage !
Ce dégainage d'armes.
On dirait moi quand je suis face à une situation de crise mec je fais exactement cette gueule.
Ça m'angoisse et ça me fait rire à la fois.
Je ne sais pas comment exprimer ce sentiment.
Ok c'est une scène d'un mec qui mange des hamburgers.
Donc du coup au début il est en mode normal et à la fin il à 1000%.
Êtes-vous prêt à découvrir cette obscénité ? Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?
Accrochez-vous bien à vos fauteuils.
Ah non, ça va être bizarre mec.
Mec il mange sa propre gueule mec,
il se mastique lui-même gros il s'auto mastique (dégout).
Mais ça n'a même plus de sens mec,
en parlant de Resident Evil 2, il y a aussi un grand méchant dans Resident Evil 2 qui s'appelle Monsieur X.
Je dis Resident Evil 2 depuis début, mais c'est le remasterisé qui est sorti il n'y a pas longtemps.
Resident Evil 2, lui est sorti il y a pas mal de temps.
Il y a vraiment tout un mythe autour de ce perso parce qu'il a sa place dans l'histoire,
il fait vraiment flipper
et il y a des mecs qui sont amusés à créer un mod où Monsieur X est remplacé par quelqu'un d'autre.
Naann ! Cours ! Tommy te suit !!! Cours !!!!
Ne le laisse pas.
Noooon !! Il n'y a pas de rail ! Comment fait-il ?
Ah, il fait peur ! Il est vraiment Creepy mec. Ahhh.
Il y a un mod aussi où Leon il est à oilp.
Voilà.Bah quelques extraits si vous voulez voir ça.
Un autre jeu dans lequel il y a eu énormément de mod,
je crois qu'au total il y en a eu plus de 40 000,
c'est Skyrim et il y a une scène trop connue au début de Skyrim
où y a un mec qui se fait exécuter devant toi, c'est au début du jeu, et tu te fais attaquer par un dragon.
Et avec ce mod, le dragon a été remplacé, mais je ne dirais pas par qui ou par quoi,
mais vous le connaissez, croyez-moi.
Tchou Tchou :).
Tiens.
Tchou Tchou.
Ahh c'est génial, je reviens au Tchou Tchou, s'il vous plaît.
Ouiiiii !!!! C'est Tommy, ah bah il fait peur mec, il fait super peur. Ah c'est fou !
Est-ce qu'un bruit est plus intimidant que le Tchou Tchou !!! Non !
C'est un gag qui a vraiment beaucoup été fait sur Skyrim,
les gens s'amusaient à changer le dragon par n'importe quoi d'autre,
mais qui ne fait trop pas peur ou qui est drôle.
J'aime le modding juste pour ça.
J'adore !
Y a des mecs qui ont mis tant d'énergie à faire un mod
où le dragon est remplacé par petit poney juste pour faire marrer la communauté.
J'aime !
Passons maintenant à mon mod préféré de Skyrim.
Un mod qui reflète ma grande maturité si jamais il y en a qui ne savent pas,
mais je ne pense pas, dans Skyrim il y a un truc qui est devenu un meme,
qui s'appelle le fus ro dah,
c'est un sort où ton perso fait un bête de cri et les ennemis en face de toi s'envole.
Et y a un mec qui a fait un mod, je vous mets les images c'est plus simple.
Ne me jugez surtout pas.
(Bruit de pet)
Je n'ai pas ri.
AHHHH !!! Tu peux faire des pets flammes mec des pets-flammes vraiment dans le jeu
et ça brûle la pauvre bête.
(Bruit de pet)
Merci !!!
Écoutez-moi bien je vais, je vais me confesser maintenant ok,
Skyrim, ce monument du jeu vidéo, je n'y ai jamais touché
et vous savez quoi il vient de se passer un truc qui illustre parfaitement ce que j'ai dit au début de la vidéo.
Je vais acheter Skyrim et l'installer uniquement pour jouer avec ce mod.
Vraiment !
Alors ensuite un classique du jeu GTA où il y a énormément de mods sur GTA IV,
mais une chiée de mods mais des skins, des mods (L'ultime bafouille) ...
Il y en a eu plein. Tu pouvais genre jouer à Iron man,
tu pouvais tirer des voitures avec tes armes, tu pouvais tirer des requins avec tes armes ...
Il y a même un mec qui a créé un mod satanique où tu peux capturer des gens avec tes pokeball,
mais genre c'est ultra glauque.
Tu pouvais aussi jouer Bob l'éponge, tu pouvais jouer une girafe, tu pouvais jouer Spider-man ...
Mais depuis il y a le jeu Spider-Man qui est sorti et qui est 20 fois mieux
donc ça ne sert plus à rien. Mais à l'époque c'était ouf vraiment !
Et passons au dernier jeu dont je vais vous parler.
De quelques mods Fallout 4. Lui aussi est un jeu édité par Bethesda.
Bethesda qui aime beaucoup les mods et qui encourage la communauté de ses jeux à créer des mods.
D'ailleurs un mec de la communauté s'est chauffé, il a créé un mod où juste tu as une poêle dans ta main.
Stylé mec.
Je sais ça paraît ridicule, mais tu peux quand même l'améliorer
en scotchant une grosse boîte en métal dedans
et elle fait encore plus mal la poêle.
Et je sais qu'avec cet argument tu vas ni télécharger le mod,
ni acheter Fallout 4 de toute manière.
Mais il y a aussi un mod dans Fallout 4 qui est débile où il y a juste un pnj,
c'est un cafard, les cafards que normalement tu butes et qui ne servent à rien dans le jeu.
Là ils en ont fait un pnj et le pnj parle et tu ne t'attends trop pas à sa voix et c'est drôle
"Holà"
Je sais ce que vous (vous ?) dites,
la poêle ne vous avait pas convaincu, vous ne vouliez pas acheter Fallout 4,
mais le cafard mec ! Le Holà du cafard vous voulez l'entendre de vos propres oreilles, n'est-ce pas ?
Écouter les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur les mods.
Je voulais en parler parce que je trouve que c'est,
c'est fou, c'est impressionnant et surtout ce n'est pas mal d'actualité
avec notamment ce qui s'est passé avec l'apparition du mod Battle Royale du coup.
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a pas mal d'énormes nouveautés
qui vont apparaître dans les années à venir dans le jeu vidéo
et qui viendront en fait d'un mec ou d'une team de mecs qui ont créé un mod d'un jeu en fait.
Mais un mod tellement incroyable, tellement cool, une idée tellement bonne
que des compagnies vont s'en inspirer pour créer un jeu à part entière avec.
Il y a des énormes boites qui pèsent, je ne sais pas combien en bourse
et qui donnent les moyens à des gens de kiffer en fait, d'exprimer leur créativité.
Et je ne sais pas,
je trouve ça assez beau cet échange entre les joueurs passionnés et les développeurs des jeux passionnés aussi
et qui permettent aux joueurs de rendre en quelque sorte hommage à leur jeu préféré en ajoutant sa petite pierre à l'édifice.
Et voilà, je ne sais pas, je trouve ça hyper touchant, hyper cool.
Ce n'était pas spécialement marrant comme vidéo, mais au moins on a appris des choses
et puis j'ai parlé d'un truc que je kiffe donc voilà.
Et qui sait peut-être que ça donnera envie à des gens d'essayer de créer des mods.
J'espère que ça vous a plu, je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
et puis portez-vous bien.
(Bruit de boîte à meuh)
Voilà une belle manière de conclure cette vidéo et ce n'était pas un mod.
*musique outo*